[Musique]
bonjour à tous dans un mois le premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle france
3 donne la parole aux représentants de
tous les candidats pour passer en revue
l'actualité de la campagne et mettre en
avant les thèmes choisis par nos invités
le sera question ce matin d'économie et
d'éducation avec nous en direct françois
xavier dugourd bonjour pour les
républicains
vous êtes et vice président du conseil
départemental de la côte d'or et
soutient donc de françois fillon fasse
avoue philippe baumel bonjour bonjour le
parti socialiste la député de
saône-et-loire et vous soutenez la
candidature de benoît hamon
yves hollinger bonjour jolie nouveau
parti anticapitaliste en côte d'or
représentant de philippe poutou
et puis maxime thibeault bonjour bonjour
monsieur légué nationale debout la
france ses soutiens de nicolas dupont
aignan je précise que l'équipe de
campagne de jacques cheminade n'a pas
donné suite à notre invitation d'un
représentant de ce candidat
en bourgogne les villes pour répondre à
une remarque d'un internaute
rappelant qu'il y avait onze candidats
nous ne l'avons pas oublié sachez que
nous organisons des débats chaque
semaine et que tout le monde aura donc
la parole selon les règles édictées par
le conseil de l'audiovisuel pour planter
le décor commençons par ce sondage
publié en fin de semaine nous sommes
d'accord il n'est le reflet de l'opinion
un instant donné
mais les chiffres peuvent expliquer
détention des changements dans les
campagnes en tête vous le voyez il y
aurait donc emmanuel macron premier tour
devant marine le pen françois fillon est
à 18 % jean-luc mélenchon très ennemis
benoît hamon douze ennemis nicolas
dupont aignan 4
les autres candidats jean lassalle à 1
nathalie arthaud philippe poutou jacques
cheminade et françois asselineau sont
créditées de moins de 0 5% d'intentions
de vote
précisons également qu'une autre étude
en début de semaine donnée pour la
bourgogne franche comté cette fois
marine le pen en tête dans notre grande
région
une question à chacun d'entre vous sur
ce qui s'est passé cette semaine
françois xavier dugourd d'abord françois
fillon perd trois points en un mois
les attaques contre françois hollande à
cette histoire de cabinet noir révélé
jeu
10 qui sera à l'origine de ses déboires
est ce que c'est la solution pour
inverser cette courbe alors déjà un
petit mot sur les sondages on se
rappelle de toute une série d'autres ces
échéances où on donnait ce type du
résultat et on a vu le résultat final et
qui était extrêmement différents c'est
pour cela que j'ai instantanément donner
des deuxièmes et les bons il semblerait
qu'ils aient encore 4 français sur 10
qui ne se soit pas prononcé et qui n'est
pas encore établi son choix alors la
stratégie par exemple attaqué françois
labat et j françois fillon les simples
c'est eux qu'on puisse parler des
projets parce que cette campagne et
l'oubli les projets et lobbys ce qu'on
veut faire pour la france elle est
aujourd'hui accaparé par sa tombe
d'affaires qui concerne d'ailleurs je
remarque un certain nombre de candidats
est donc l'objectif de françois fillon
c'est qu'on parle enfin du fond c'est à
dire c'est ce qui c'est ça l'enjeu de
ces élections présidentielles et à
partir de là effectivement il a fait le
constat d'un certain nombre de choses
sur ce qu'il est il est attaqué et
semble-t-il par la justice plusieurs
constats premièrement c'est que cette
justice de manière assez exceptionnelle
va très vite on sait qu'en france il ya
quand même des des lenteurs de la
justice
c'est semble-t-il pas le cas sur la
sphère qui le concerne et deuxièmement
il ya quelque chose qui est absolument
hallucinant c'est la façon dont un stand
d'information qui concerne cette
instruction judiciaire qui doit aller au
bout et qui doit être porté de manière
juste et équilibrée entre les
accusations et les défenseurs il ya un
certain nombre d'informations qui sont
publiés dans la presse ça veut dire que
françois fillon il est jugé il est jugé
avant enfin il est même condamné avant
de pouvoir s exprimer
alors restez fondu et donc être jugé
c'est quand même absolument hallucinant
un complot ferme semble plausible fait
les beaux mâles françois hollande n ya
pas de complot je pense que tout ça
c'est un écran de fumée que monsieur
fillon veut orchestrée en vérité pour ne
pas parler davantage de son projet mais
pour éviter que l'on parle du fond des
choses est en vérité malheureusement les
fautes commises dont il s'est d'ailleurs
lui-même exclusive déjà à plusieurs
reprises
sauf que dans ce pays il ya un droit il
ya d'un certain nombre de lois qu'il
faut savoir respecter et
particulièrement lorsqu'on est président
la république
on se doit d'être exempt de toute
propension au doute à cette capacité
d'avoir faut pas respecter les lois et
le pilote puisqu'il ça n'est déjà excusé
à trois reprises il a donc bien fait la
preuve
n'avait pas respecté la loi pas plus
pour les appeler l'emploi de son épouse
dont personne aujourd'hui même pas lui
ne peut attester qu'elle a jamais
travaillé pour lui et pas plus non plus
pour ces cadeaux faramineux qu'il reçoit
dont il nous dit lui même qui sont
désintéressés
mais enfin quand on voit les sommes
astronomiques que ça concerne
sincèrement ça devient une descente
non je pense en vérité qu'il y a un vrai
problème avec cette candidature est une
candidature qui est hors des clous et
aujourd'hui on essaie de créer une
affaire dans la sphère avec la stratégie
du cabinet noir que l'on a sorti que
d'un roman de féerique en quelque sorte
ni qui ne correspond à rien en ce qui
concerne la réalité exercice ce sujet
yves hollinger m'écouter de toute façon
la justice effectivement en france des
fois curieusement rapide mais pas
forcément pour les mêmes personnes
parce que quand philippe poutou
manifeste au salon de l'auto durant le
stand de ford pour défendre son emploi
parce que lui c'est sa survie économique
et social qu'il défende ex de ses
camarades de travail
là il est convoqué en un temps record
effectivement devant le tribunal donc et
comme d'autres syndicalistes comme
beaucoup de comparution immédiate et
ainsi de suite
alors de ce point de vue là
effectivement il ya bien ajuster sa vie
à deux vitesses dans ce pays
mais les résultats des investigations
sont pas les mêmes pour tout le monde
moi je suis fatigué je suis fatigué de
ces affaires on a 30 jours de l'élection
présidentielle
on parle pas du tout les problèmes hier
j'avais un pompiers de chalon sur saône
au téléphone qui le disaient que le
manque de moyens étaient plus en plus
criants nos services publics sont plus
en plus délaissée et là on nous sort la
sphère du cabinet noir à chaque fois
qu'un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle s'est trouvé en chute
libre il a sorti le cabinet noir du
gouvernement donc je pense que monsieur
fillon est totalement ratiboiser de
cette élection présidentielle qu'il faut
incarner une vraie politique à droite
que nicolas dupont aignan à 15,7
politiques aussi bien sur le programme
que sur l'éthique et les valeurs du
candidat parce que le vrai problème
c'est qu'à droite on attend quelqu'un
qui en tout cas incarner une certaine
carrure et ce n'est plus le cas de
monsieur fillon
en tout cas moi je trouve totalement
indigne qui se soit fait payer des
costards enfin moi je travaille pour
payer mes costard je vous dire de celui
ci m'a coûté 300 euros mes chaussettes
qui viennent de chez perrin
à montceau les mines m ont coûté une
vingtaine d'euros en tout cas je les ai
payés je sais la valeur travail
je sais ce que c'est derrière et quand
on voit dix mille euros payés par une
personne d'autre quand on voit des
montres quand on va tout un tas
d'affaires
mais cette personne est totalement
déconnectée des réalités et je ne vois
pas dans quelle mesure elle pourrait
représenter les français pendant cinq
ans autre actualité de la semaine les
soutiens à emmanuel macron ils sont
nombreux à gauche comme à droite il ait
eu dominique perben cette semaine
l'ancien maire de chalon et ancien
ministre de jacques chirac philippe
baumel vous avez des mots très durs
envers ceux qui quittent le navire
socialiste pour rejoindre emmanuel
macron comme l'ex-ministre jean yves le
drian
pourquoi n'y aurait-il pas des
ralliements sincère lui parce que tout
ça vient à point nommé et totalement
orchestrée quand vous voyez jour après
jour s'égrainer certains aliments et pas
d'autres quand on voit où combien les
médias sont attirés pour parler de ces
ralliements parce qu'il s'agit
évidemment de personnalités
significative quand j'apprends par
exemple que le ministre de la défense
socialiste choisi le jour où le candidat
socialiste présente son projet en
matière de défense pour dire que
finalement il le lâche
je considère ce que cela n'est pas
acceptable on ne peut pas être membre
d'un parti politique et ne pas respecter
les choix qui sont faits non seulement
par les militants de ce parti politique
mais en plus par tous ceux qui ont
accepté de participer aux primaires et
qui ont fait un libre choix à gauche de
choisir à plus de 2 millions benoît
hamon donc voilà il ya une logique en
quelque sorte lorsqu'on veut construire
dans une démarche notamment deux
présidentielles et si on sen exempt ça
veut dire qu'on est en quelque sorte un
diviseur peut être même un casseur de
son propre camp les ralliements à gauche
comme à droite
c'est vrai que c'est logique on a du mal
à veut la suivre à gauche nettement
monsieur belle parce que donc évidemment
les années 2000 on a mis les nerfs des
aînés de dijon pour le meeting jeudi
avait déjà de la gauche et de la droite
mais vous défendez un candide et à vous
défendez accorder à monsieur hamon pour
porter la candidature de monsieur hamon
qui était un frondeur de monsieur
hollande inquiète donc combattu la
politique de monsieur hollande
maintenant vous revendiquez la politique
de monsieur hollande parce que j'ai
compris c'est quand même non enfin c'est
quand même votre capital vous êtes que
je compte sur les bonnes réponses et
principaux ses principaux ministres
parti chez monsieur macron donc on
effectivement un peu de mal à suivre la
gauche honnêtement parce qu'il n'y a pas
de projet parce qu'en fait vous êtes
d'accord sur rien vous êtes d'accord sur
rien y'a rien qui vous lie n'y a pas de
projet c'est toute la différence avec
françois fillon et son programme le
candidat de françois hollande c'est
macro tout cas on est en train de voir
un hollande beasley entre un appareil
qui s'appelle monsieur macron la
primaire socialiste elle se joue au
premier tour de la présidentielle
et moi je trouve que c'est bien parce
qu'en réalité ses premiers tours de la
présidentielle où les gens doivent
choisir et c'est pour ça que j'étais
contre la logique total des primaires
finalement la vie à un mauvais candidat
à droite on voit un mauvais candidat à
gauche dont on ne sait bien le seul à
jouer au premier tour le problème c'est
monsieur macron c'est impossible on a
une fausse info modernisme en fait c'est
un peu comme un iphone vous achetez un
iphone non plus pur style vous propose
n'est pas ce qu'il semble moderne et au
bout de deux semaines vous rendez compte
que finalement il est pas mieux que les
autres et bakr on sait un iphone de la
politique dans deux semaines on va se
rendre compte qu'il sert à rien et ya
aucune idée et ça c'est dramatique
et voilà je vous êtes en retard patent
de lorient c'est clair que je pense qui
concerne la candidature macron cette
formation avant attrape tout de ce point
de vue là il guère de doute maintenant
ce qui éclaire aussi c'est que la
politique de monsieur macro vise à
prolonger clairement et nettement la
politique faussement gauche cas
pratiques et monsieur hollande pendant
cinq mandats et la prolonge à la dure
six ans jusque par dans son cousin me
lisent même à durcir la loi comrie que
tous ceux qui lisent sont réellement
convaincu de l'intérêt des classes
populaires 9,9 rejetées dont abolir et
s'engager à abolir
à l'occasion ce scrutin notamment nous
parlons des programmes des candidats
dans cette émission chaque dimanche
vous avez souhaité parler d'économie et
l'éducation commençons par l économie
avec vous philippe baumel dans le
programme de benoît hamon au moins 50%
des marchés publics français doivent
bénéficier à des pme tpe pmi ou à des
structures d'économie sociale et
solidaire comment mettre en place cette
mesure
la procédure d'appel d'offres fait que
toutes les entreprises peuvent
participer pas que des tpe ou des
entreprises que l'on veut privilégier
oui mais je crois qu'on peut faire en
sorte notamment en introduisant de
nouvelles clauses notamment
environnementales ou sociales mettre en
capacité justement des critères nouveaux
qu'ils fléchiront elle plus ou moins
directement vers les entreprises dont un
territoire donné
les marchés de 2
le nombre de collectivités notamment et
de l'état aussi je pense que c'est très
important parce que ça permettra
véritablement de faire en sorte que
l'argent qui est payé par les
contribuables à travers leurs impôts
bénéficie véritablement au développement
du territoire où ils vivent et des
entreprises où ils vivent et à la
création d'emplois en proximité
je pense que c'est une des solutions
qu'il faut savoir exercer et c'est très
important aussi par rapport à l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui s'est beaucoup
développée ces dernières années pour
être en capacité justement delà de l'afp
au delà privilégié de la favorisés parce
qu'on sait qu'elle correspond aussi à un
public de chômeurs qui sont durablement
parfois dans le chômage qui ont besoin
d'être accompagnés dans des entreprises
qui savent les accompagner justement
pour le retour durable à l'emploi
et bien ces entreprises il focalisait le
syntagme le marché s'est donc
privilégier le made in france maxime
c'est beau c'est un thème qui devrait
vous nous parler oui bien sûr mais moi
je suis assez scandalisé sous le
précédent gouvernement on a une réforme
du code des marchés publics carrément
une suppression du code avait une loi
illisible moi par exemple je suis
juriste des collectivités territoriales
on a mis six mois à la comprendre
imaginez les tpe les pme le temps
qu'elles ont mise pour le comprendre
c'est quand même le gouvernement
socialiste il a mis en place au final ce
sont des grosses voix qui sont
privilégiées par rapport aux pme ou tpe
j'en parlais à la capeb vendredi soir à
chalon-sur-saône où bizarrement il n'y
avait pas de représentant du mois n'y
avait pas de représentant de monsieur
hamon digne de ce nom c'est à dire que
madame unter mayer qui est député
socialiste a refusé de venir et a
préféré envoyer en six collaborateurs
sous-entendu bon on n'est pas trop
intéressé par la question de l'emploi
local mais il faut c'est sûr privilégier
la l'achat dans la commande publique de
produits locaux
c'est pourquoi nicolas dupont aignan
veut tout 75% de l'achat public soient
réservés à des entreprises qui
produisent en france et 50% à des pme
locales
pourtant vous aviez de cet accord avec
ce qui s'est dit simplement il faut
distinguer la parole et les actes nous
nous agissons
c'est à dire que moi je suis vice
premier vice président du conseil
départemental de la côte d'or
aujourd'hui 85% de nos marchés sont
attribués à des pme du département suit
présidents des offices hlm orvitis et
c'est la même proportion pourquoi parce
qu'on a travaillé de manière très
concrète avec les fédérations
professionnelles dont le respect du code
des marchés publics pour permettre aux
pme aux entreprises de notre département
de train
ayé en côte-d'or et de créer de l'emploi
en côte d'or je crois que c'est ça au
delà des faits t-bonds d'un certain
nombre de freins nationaux il faut
effectivement jamais responsabilités ils
puissent appliquer ce que leurs
promesses et nous le faisons ça nous le
faisons on peut quand on voyait la balle
à l autre la directive bolkenstein de
2006 sur les travailleurs détachés
elle a été mise en place par le
gouvernement fillon et ensuite elle a
été avalisé par le gouvernement de
monsieur valls c'est à dire les deux
gouvernements vous avez été tous les
deux d'accord mettre en place une
directive de travailleurs détachés qui
fait que des travailleurs qui viennent
de pays étrangers sont payés au salaire
france m avec les charges du pays
d'origine je suis désolé jusqu'au moment
où la crise est arrivée où les artisans
commencé à se rebeller là on a vu tout
le monde mais attention la directive les
travailleurs détachés faut la remettre
en cause
le problème c'est qu'on a perdu dix ans
et on a eu un million de chômeurs sous
gouvernement monsieur fillon
un million de chômeurs sous gouvernement
de monsieur valls il voit large et sur
ce sujet parce que ça c'est bien joli
mais des pourcentages de garantie
d'emploi telata le cas ça passe
fondamentalement déjà par l'emploi et
pas par les marchés les codes à revoir
et ainsi de suite
et la première chose assuré c'est tout
simplement d'interdire les licenciements
et de créer les emplois correspondants
on a par exemple la en charges
patronales qui ont été dégagés d'une
manière ou d'une autre ne fut-ce que
pendant le mandat récent le précédent
n'a pas fait mieux
presque l'ordre de 60 milliards d'euros
qui aurait très bien pu être utilisées
c'est l'ensemble des charges patronales
ce quoi il parle de charges non parle de
cadeaux
s'élançant d'eca2 que et fr de l'année
2016 avec ça j'ai de quoi assurer à
échéant à hauteur des 1700 euros que
nous revendiquons deux millions
d'emplois dans ce pays et bien d'autres
choses
comment c'est à dire les l'instant c'est
moi précisé mme bintou simplement en
prenant les mesures nécessaires parce
que si on ne donne pas de l'emploi si on
n'augmente pas les salaires et si on
diminue pack temps de travail pour le
répartir entre toutes les personnes qui
cherchent du travail actuellement on
continuera à avoir 8 millions cinq cent
mille personnes pauvres dans ce pays et
16 millions de personnes qui cherchent
un logement de qualité etc etc
il faut attaquer à la racine et pas des
mesurettes comme on fait les
gouvernements
moi je mets 75 moi je vais 50 moi je
fais preuve se montrer
à moi de ce que je vais faire un
politique est en réalité c'est les mêmes
mesures depuis barre et puis c'est
différent tuque et compagnie la rose le
jardin au lieu de leur remettra en route
compte correctement plutôt gauche du ps
si on peut dire gauche de la gauche ça
vous parle ces mesures d'interdiction
des licenciements ça vous semble et de
noix de muscade et actions des
licenciements est complètement illusoire
nageuse du système dans lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui sincèrement je ne
vois pas comment on pourrait interdire
licenciement parce qu'il ya une réalité
économique qui s'impose à un moment
donné quand une entreprise n'a plus de
marché elle va pas garder ses employés
parce que tout simplement il ne pourra
pas les payer donc je pense en revanche
qu'il ya des méthodes pour arriver à
plus d'emplois la question patients qui
vit naître évoqué qui me paraît tout à
fait justes qui est celle du partage du
temps de travail ne paraît tout à fait
pertinente je rappelle que la dernière
fois dans ce pays on a créé un million
de deux emplois nouveaux
ça a été grâce à la mise en place des 35
heures que monsieur fillon veut abroger
dont je lui souhaite vraiment que ils
n'arrivent pas au pouvoir plus pour
pouvoir exercer ce type de réforme parce
qu'à ce moment là on va voir l'effet que
ça va produire notamment sur des choses
sur les chômeurs âgés qui sont déjà
particulièrement nombreux et qui le
seront davantage encore si on prolonge
naturellement et on retire et en ragan
rallonge jusqu'à 65 ans le pou la
possibilité de pouvoir partir à la
retraite je pense que tout au contraire
il faut partager le travail parce que le
travail est rare parce qu'il ya aussi
une robotisation qui est en marche et
donc il faut être en capacité de
partager le travail pour partager les
revenus et pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait moins de chômeurs dans ce pays
françois laval temps pour aller dire
rejoindre 10 juin la filiale de ge et
berit qui est en train d'être liquidé
allait leur dit qu'on prend pas des
mesures pour empêcher qu'ils soient
licenciés la salle sbk est dur et joyeux
mesures à prendre évidemment voir et de
l'est derrière ça qu'il faut à la
veillée dites-le à eux comme à sanofi
comme à d'autres
moi j'ai le sentiment que ce discours
ils sont assez éloignées la réalité
économique
quand je suis en temps monsieur baumel
et donc monsieur hamon parler d'une taxe
sur les robots
c'est complètement effarant que d'être
aussi déconnectée de la réalité
économique aujourd'hui les payer les
pays aujourd'hui décédé les payeurs les
pays européens les pays européens
mondiaux
l'emploi ce sont ce sont ceux qui sont
les plus avancés en matière de
robotisation c'est une évidence parce
que aujourd'hui c'est la compétitivité
des entreprises qui est en jeu et ça
passe par des robots ça veut pas dire du
tout suppression de l'emploi bien au
contraire ça veut dire suppression d'un
certain nombre de tâches répétitives
dans l'entreprise pour permettre pour
permettre d'être beaucoup plus
compétitifs sur les marchés par rapport
à nos concurrents qui ont qui sont
passés à la robotisation depuis bien
longtemps aujourd'hui nous l'économie
française est derrière des serres de
marché c'est parce que nous on n'est pas
suffisamment avancée sur ces dossiers
vous êtes complètement déconnecté de la
réalité économique mondiale jamais moi
ce qui fait rire quand même pour ne pas
dire pleurer sept jeux sous les 10
dernières années tous les fleurons
industriels français pratiquement ont
été lâchés par le gouvernement c'est
vrai regardez à le faire du
catastrophisme 7 vous êtes allés avec
toute affaire d'issa trio tic c'est pas
vrai patriotisme et même mon tout
nouveau mais ces salariés surnom de
tenir sa mère indigne monsieur macro
cefic a revendu à l'automne en général
on est tous inscrits sont des cas pas
des quartiers des caricatures une soirée
qui avait causé vision de monsieur jo
révoquera j'aimerais savoir quels seront
les puissances industrielles françaises
à ces problèmes et quand je vois qu'à
six hommes dont je vois quatre tomes
avec son joyau à kallstrom a été lâché à
general electric et qu'on sait que
derrière ce sera à terme la
délocalisation nos emplois c'est
scandaleux
moi je suis allé faire les
manifestations à belfort et je sais ce
qui s'est passé cette en réalité votre
gouvernement est totalement soumis à des
intérêts privés qui sont malheureusement
étrangers qui a plus de politique
industrielle en france et plus de
développement et ses pattes jaunes et
noirs monsieur c'est un cabinet noir
c'est le fait que vous vous soumettez
dans vos décisions à bruxelles aux
intérêts étrangers aux intérêts
financiers et ya plus du tout de vision
politique d'avenir
regardez la situation du nucléaire
regardez la situation de l'innovation
dans les nouvelles technologies
il n'y a plus rien dans ce pays parce
que des gouvernements ont abandonné les
français et ça ça me met hors de moi
on a entendu phénomène d'abord la
réponse écoutez moi je vais pas répondre
à ces à ces arguties qui à mon avis sont
très très loin de là
réalité alternée et de l'économie du
pays dans sa synthèse entre deux files
de sa filière essentiel aujourd'hui
sincèrement il ya un énorme effort qui a
été fait par le gouvernement actuel et
son prédécesseur notamment dans la
filière nucléaire on le sait dans ce
pays et coûté pas plus tard que
avant-hier en saône-et-loire areva
annoncé qu'ils embauchent 200 personnes
de plus si ça allait si mal que ça je
pense qu'il ne le ferait pas pas plus
tard qu'il ya un mois alstom annoncé
aussi dans ma circonscription qui créer
une cinquantaine d'emplois
supplémentaires donc je pense qu'il faut
regarder les choses en face il ya un
certain nombre de grands groupes qui
fonctionne bien qu'ils attrapent des
marchés sur le plan international et qui
ont besoin d'être accompagné
probablement pour véritablement gagner
davantage de marchés le président la
république est aujourd'hui à singapour
notamment parce qu'il y aura il aura
assigné un certain nombre de contrat sur
le rafale et je ne pense pas que le
groupe dassault s'en plaigne
particulièrement et encore mois les
salariés du groupe dassault je pense en
vérité que il faut par contre être
exigeants lorsqu'il ya des aides de
l'état pour qu'elle soit fléchi et
véritablement non pas vers les
actionnaires mais vers les entreprises
la principale critique que j'ai eu à
faire sur le cic eu par exemple en tant
que part de parlementaires socialistes
c'est qu' aucune condition n'a été mise
à 7 à ce cadeau qui a été fait un
certain nombre d'entreprises
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 40
milliards d'euros qui ont été distribués
ce que l'on constate malheureusement que
c'est que cet argent là n'est pas allé
vers l'innovation pas aller vers la
recherche de compétitivité la plupart du
temps il est allé vers le divers et
dividendes des actionnaires ça ça n'est
pas acceptable
je pense qu'en vérité si on veut
retrouver de toute la force nécessaire à
notre économie
il faut que lorsqu'il ya des aides
publiques véritablement elles soient
utilisés dans l'entreprise pour
développer l'entreprise et il faut aussi
que lorsqu'une entreprise lorsqu'on
constate qu'elle n'a pas utilisé cet
argent correctement il faut exiger le
remboursement de ses succès du salon
combiné non plus alcatel jouer en france
avec moi il vaut la ga fera par sachet
haut-parleurs passe au chapitre
éducation que ce qui nous restait très
peu de temps on va y arriver mais je
pense qu'elle me remarque à faire c'est
que tout ça c'est par rapport à des
situations qui sont en crise on nous
vend quelques embauches areva etc et où
est la transition écologique tentait ce
qu'on décidera faire ce qu'ils étaient
engagés ou moins partiellement
on n'a pas fait en effet son naim on n'a
aucune des promesses des candidats ne
t'étais là dessus on en est toujours
à ne pas savoir quoi faire des déchets
on est toujours à vouloir installer une
poubelle nucléaires à bure et ainsi de
suite
la transition écologique est un
engagement sous lesquelles l'ensemble
aux citoyennes et citoyens sont
attentifs et nous pensons que toutes les
propositions qui sont faites là ont
l'immense inconvénients de contrôler
complètement les conséquences de cette
conception productiviste de la société
l'éducation c'est l'un des thèmes que
vous avez souhaité aborder également
françois xavier dugourd avec françois
fillon
l'éducation est elle toujours national
il souhaite que les collectivités
territoriales décide des rythmes
scolaires plus d'indépendance des
régions des établissements ça veut dire
que tu as plus d'éducation nationale en
france moi je pense que c'est vraiment
un sujet fondamental dont on parle pas
suffisamment sûre chez le sujet
l'éducation trois constats premièrement
notre pays
toutes les études internationales
démontrent à une qualité anciennement
pas suffisante
malgré les moyens considérables qui sont
donnés depuis de longues années
2e deuxième constat unis n'est
inadéquation entre l'offre de formation
et les besoins d'emploi et les besoins
d'emplois dans notre pays ils sont
nombreux j'étais hier aux rencontres
organisées par lui et même en côte d'or
il y avait trente entreprises qui
étaient présentes 450 emplois à pourvoir
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont pas pourvus
par l'offre de formation donc on a une
vraie inadéquation et troisièmement un
problème que l'éducation l'enseignement
professionnel et technique aujourd'hui
dans notre pays il est dévalorisé donc
on a un travail fondamental à faire ça
passe par les propositions de françois
fillon premièrement d'agir sur les
fondamentaux à l'école à l'école au
collège au lycée ça veut dire savoir
lire compter calculé lire et écrire
simplement des avaloirs youri oui mais
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut
avancer la scolarité obligatoire à cinq
ans il faut une action tu es sur les
enseignements fondamentaux quand au sort
aujourd'hui de l'école primaire il ya
environ 40% des élèves qui maîtrisent
pas qu'ils maîtrisent pas véritablement
la lecture ni les chiffres décimaux
c'est quand même effarant et autres
réformes fondamentales développer
l'alternance développer l'apprentissage
pour que le lien entre l'entreprise et
l'appareil de qatif sont beaucoup plus
forts donner plus de pouvoir aux régions
certainement qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
pop
je des réalités économiques pour adapter
à une offre de formation aux besoins des
entreprises
yann l'emploi en france il ya beaucoup
de secteurs aujourd'hui n'est pas
pourvus parce que notre appareil de
formation l'autre éducation elle est mal
faite
maxime goisset thèmes que vous
souhaitiez développer aussi dans le
programme de nicolas dupont aignan parle
de conditionner le versement des
allocations familiales à l'assiduité
scolaire ou encore de remettre sur le
terrain des personnels administratifs ça
veut dire que les profs ne font pas leur
boulot
aujourd'hui on souhaite surtout leur
donner un statut parce que le problème
c'est les professeurs aujourd'hui ou à
mes amis qui sont professeurs ils sont
payés au lance-pierre hausse un métier
qui n'attire plus et pourtant ce sont
les hussards de la république c'est à
dire ceux qui doivent instruire notre
population déjà à sable très simple on
veut plus parler d'éducation nationale
d'être mais d'instruction publique parce
que l'objectif de l'école c'est de
sortir en sachant lire compter et en
connaissant l'histoire de notre pays est
le vrai problème c'est qu'on a
totalement abandonné cette vision là on
a préféré mettre en place des nappes qui
ont permis à des gamins de jouer à la
baballe
à la fin des cours plutôt que leur aider
à apprendre les enseignements
fondamentaux et ça c'est scandaleux
parce que l'idée derrière c'est quand
même d'avoir un peuple cultivé
vous savez il ya une citation condorcet
qui est très bien qu'ils disaient
l'esclavagé l'ignorance toujours même à
la servitude et c'est ça le vrai
problème
philippe baumel sur ses mises en place
d'un nouveau système de nouveaux rythmes
beaucoup veulent abroger nouveau rythme
scolaire et la réforme du collège alors
souligné sur les nappes en fait les
nouveaux rythmes scolaires qui ont été
envisagées il faut râler qui ont été mis
en place il faut rappeler que c'est une
réforme d'égalité nous avions constaté
épanouir politique mais l'ensemble de
ceux qui se préoccupent de
l'environnement de l'école qu'il y à de
très fortes inégalités par rapport à
l'accès à la connaissance par rapport à
l'axé un certain nombre de vecteurs
culturels qui existe est partout sur le
territoire national et qu'il fallait
essayer de les corriger
ce que je constate moi personnellement
même dans ma circonscription c'est que
les nappes ont été mises en place à
géométrie variable en fonction des
moyens que les collectivités ont bien
voulu mettre à disposition en fait de ce
qui aujourd'hui participe à la cena
jusqu'au stade
je constate que je coache pas alors je
suis je suis d'accord sur cette remarque
parce que je pense qu'en vérité il lui
fallu envisager un financement par
l'état au moins partiel 2 sénat pour
qu'on soit sûr de pouvoir aussi vérif
et la qualité de l'information qui est
afférente et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est
proposé aujourd'hui par françois parent
par benoît hamon qui veut véritablement
pouvoir remettre en selle des nappes
pouvoir contrôler ce qui est fait à
travers
je rappelle quand même aussi par rapport
à ce qui a été dit gêné raisonnement par
monsieur dieu pour ses 40 ans juste un
instant avec un vérité parce que
françois fillon était au pouvoir il a
quand même supprimé 12000 postes
d'enseignants donc du métier de
l'enseignant et volage et 35 entre les
classes et du rationnement passe aussi
par l'arrêt des suppressions de postes
et matic et qui n'ont pas seulement
étaient le fait de l'avant dernier
mandat
c'est une politique assez généralisé je
rappelle que antérieurement avait aussi
retiré l'éducation nationale
les personnels administratifs qui sont
quand même un maillon indispensable mais
bon fonctionnement car tout ne repose
pas sur l'enseignant oui j'ai hélas
manque des dizaines de milliers donc il
faut continuer on doit arriver à autre
chose qu'un enseignement qui soit un
enseignement je dirais à de masse comme
on le fait actuellement alors qu'on a
besoin d'une situation dont les sardines
on peut les mettre 20 par boîte mais pas
les enfants conforme et si on veut
qu'ils aillent vers effectivement des
solutions des perspectives ya pas
seulement les éléments fondamentaux et
aux six le savoir existent dans la
société et ça c'est ça la fin mars dans
un fonctionnement général et rssi et
avec des effectifs réduits par classe et
gaza tous les cas d'avoir participé
merci à vous de nous avoir regardé
dimanche en politique et deuxième partie
avec francis letellier c'est juste après
l'info en bourgogne présenté par
emmanuel par sono n'oublie pas le 110 le
sidaction pour vos promesses de dons
très bon week end
bon dimanche sur france 3
[Musique]
lundi